[Music]
I am honored to introduce to you the
creator of The Hunger Games themselves
Dean casca High bottom
I have summoned you all here for the
10th Annual reaping ceremony in which we
choose two children from each district
to fight to the death in The Hunger
Games from District 12 Lucy gray bear
[Music]
there has been a change this year as a
mentor Mr snow Your Role is to turn
these children into spectacles not
survivors
invest to take care of you
carry me in that Arena
you start by thinking I can actually win
I'm lucky flickerman first ever host of
The Hunger Games enjoy the show bye
enjoy the show
what happens in there
filled with the terror becoming prey
see how quickly we become predator
see how quickly civilization disappears
[Music]
there's a natural goodness built into us
all
across that line into evil
or not
you hear that boy
it's the sound of snow
falling
how wonderful that we all get to be here
for someone's final performance it's not
everything is about winning
monsters
it's the things we love most
destroy us
[Music]